hey yeah hello Kimiko
[Laughter]
yes sir help me
[Music]
and today we bring you another scam
story huh what's this game
what's the skin what do you guys think
the scams about what's the industry of
scamming what's the location at
ooh this one uh outer space technically
whoa what the hell let me scam some
aliens
what's your theory can they scam some
alien like how the aliens came and then
the governments like hey let's scam
these guys okay how do you think
okay let's scam these guys they're the
aliens got there and they're like hey
you know
um so everyone on this planet's actually
gone already so you're a little late to
the party and then the aliens are like
all right so they just left so that was
the scam that's it no monitoring they
just live straight up lied dude so close
man so close spot on almost huh yeah
almost they saved the world out of the
scam I'll stick in Russia Maybe
how the [ __ ] do you know that well only
a few countries have access to space
look at you you're [ __ ] hot wow
and Russia seems kind of shady these
days I don't think so man so
so a man claiming to be a Russian
astronaut in space allegedly scammed a
Japanese woman into paying for his
return trip to Earth for an astronaut
food vowing to marry her once he landed
whoa wow it [ __ ] got this dress that
worked Cafe dude that's the new move man
from space yeah you got to get more
creative you know yeah use the photo
booth [ __ ] uh it's like Fast and
Furious
12.00 yeah hello Kimiko
[Laughter]
yes sir
no I can't suck I ran out of oxygen
buddy
I'm gonna die damn that's the ultimate
coverage
here we go
yeah this uh the man found the 65 year
old unnamed victim on Instagram now we
know it's Kimiko it's chemical yeah her
name is uh so he found her on Instagram
in June
on his profile he uploaded random photos
of space and said he worked at the
International Space Station that's all
you got to do these days I knew his ISS
[ __ ] another one of those where
astronauts have limited access to cell
service
their relationship quickly escalated and
on the Japanese messaging app line he
repeatedly said he loved her
and proposed marriage whoa messages like
quote I want to start my life in Japan
and saying
um things like this one thousand times
won't be enough I'll keep saying it I
love you so you like really [ __ ]
played to her Hearts right but to
actually tie the knot he said he needed
money to return to Earth a second space
the space toll because a [ __ ] Chevron
what doesn't accept card up there
were there were Landing fees obviously
to pay once in Japan and the cost of a
rocket to actually fly to the country
um believing this man would be her
future fiance the woman paid him about
4.4 million yen which is about thirty
thousand dollars in five installments
from August 19th to September 5th sad
sad bro
but when his demands continued the woman
grew suspicious of his intent and
reported him to the police who invest
the Space Police the space to to uh to
uh what's his face from from the office
what's his name Steve Carell Steve
Carell yeah there it is a [ __ ] yeah
um but yeah like when his demands
continue she reported to the police who
are investigating the case as a romance
scam uh romance scams when a criminal
creates a fake online identity to gain a
victim's trust to dupe them into sending
that money has been increasing in Japan
specifically because they're lonely out
there man yeah they are lonely out there
huh it wasn't very trusty wasn't uh Joe
talking about how their like population
is like declining and stuff too so
they're probably not getting the you
know the ugly bumpings going on and the
in-cell rates going up too there's like
a statistic on that yeah that's what Joe
says it's a national average what do you
check stats the website the national
website for Japan how do you spell that
uh Nippon inside daily
that's what it was
[Laughter]
excuse me
updates to the day every day and updates
no scams here yeah updated daily it's
sad that like you know how like elderly
people do get scammed a lot but it sucks
that like when you think about damn how
do you get to 65 in like amass that
amount of knowledge to be scammed by
something that dreamy that like space
was around when she was young I think
it's the platform you know what I mean
maybe she's 65 she knows things about
like the the broader world but like once
it goes to Instagram Suddenly It's like
if you haven't been scammed by social
media everybody yeah everyone's
everybody has got yeah everybody has got
that's really sad and I think for older
people it's just how they get got is on
a way crazier scale yeah it's like when
we get caught on social media for the
first time we're like still young so our
scams are relative to our our age right
but like an adult that's an
Intergalactic grift like it's not even
this is newsworthy let's be fair about
that this is newsworthies I guess cam on
Instagram by buying a pair of shorts I'm
like oh these are cool like I'm gonna
buy these and then you're like what the
[ __ ] barbell not even that it's it's
like it's like it's a sponsored one
right I buy it it comes like
10 weeks later it's only from China
right and I get it in this [ __ ] bag
and I'm like this looks nothing like
what I bought yeah they just send you
some random [ __ ] that's how I got got so
I feel exactly what she's feeling yeah
really similar I don't know if that's
getting God or not no no I spent 24.99
and I spent an extra 49 for shipping and
I got up 49 for shipping is really good
yeah but it wasn't as advertised like
the space man she bought but that's like
the equivalent would be a guy messaging
you from [ __ ] space saying I found
some shorts can you pay me money I'll
send them to you yeah found some shorts
on a [ __ ] asteroid it was kind of
like that if you think about it it's so
far out that it's like damn Kimiko come
on let me go I guess I guess uh Japanese
chicks really like space or maybe her
desire for love was just that intense
that she wanted to believe anything that
was outer space but these guys that are
missing something in their life so bad
and they're getting sold a dream you
know like these people know how to
Target the heartstrings that's true they
are really good because how many other
people has he done that to but that's
also why sometimes I blame the victim
I'm a victim blamer myself I have people
let's uh let's quote that one you know
when you go when you get like the uh
have you guys ever participated in the
Nigerian prince Camp yeah so
participated yeah so in college oh like
you try to go along with it yeah yeah
like in college
um I was selling these like subwoofers
on Craigslist I don't want them anymore
and then
um like I think I've done enough shady
[ __ ] where I could just smell Shady like
right off the bat so this email comes
back all [ __ ] formal and [ __ ] with
like way too much information and
details trying to be like super proper
I'm like oh this is but I'm interested
because I've never participated in one
before yeah so so he pretty much said
like
um oh yeah I would love these speakers
they fit my car perfectly I did all the
measurements and you know and then he
was like but the problem is
um like the only way for me to send you
money is we have to like sync our
accounts so if you if I'll send you I'll
send you like 10 G's uh through like
Western Union or some [ __ ] and then uh
you just need to send me back like a
grand or something like some [ __ ]
like that oh no you send me back 90s
because I think I was selling Silvers
for like a grand so like obviously the
math is like I'm like no one like bets
like if you play poker no one bets 20
G's to make a hundred dollars like
that's [ __ ] dumb and then I was like
but it was so interesting that I was
like oh you know what like
um I actually can't read that well I'm
like can we jump on the phone and he
actually jumped on the phone with me
tight and then you can hear like it
sounds like a satellite phone where it's
like
it's just like a Dorito bag
but then it would have like a two second
delay and all that stuff and I was like
oh man these guys are getting really
really like committed and I was like
okay what's the next step and we'll send
you the checks so they actually sent me
checks and it's printed on like
cashier's check paper wow there's
texture to it yeah and I'm like holy
[ __ ] this is crazy and I even wanted to
just test to see like if it how far I
would go so I think I went to the post
office or Western Union wherever you
cash those things and I try to cattle oh
man this is fake dude I was like damn it
because I thought I could scam him
dude there's got to be I'll just keep
the tensions for sure I forget what the
name is but there's a YouTube channel of
a guy who's a hacker and he scams the
scammers Steve Green comedy I've seen
yeah it's a dude that like gets on their
webcams or [ __ ] right yeah does he ever
take money from them nah he's like an
ethical no but he deletes like he he
finds a way to get into the laptop and
he deletes their files yeah he [ __ ] the
company that's like because it's a whole
floor of people how to do it I forgot
what country it's in but then he he like
found out the whole floor and they all
like yeah I think it's in India or
Bangladesh but then like because the
country that they're in also doesn't
want them doing that so he'll report
them and the cops in that area will like
take it down dude that guy should
[ __ ] vigilante heroism [ __ ] and just
attack everybody that's doing that [ __ ]
and just like I would I would I would
donate to his cause like we all donate
to conium all right but that's what he's
trying to do is he's trying to set up an
actual task force like a department that
handles that like foreign scamming
because there is none really there's no
specialized Department that'll like take
it down he wants to start it but like
for Interpol or some [ __ ] yeah but then
he said like you can't take him down
faster than they can go back up like
there's no way you know but still tired
yeah but he learns their names like he
gets their files uh I think he he had at
one point deleted the majority of the
stuff on this guy's computer and they
got the scammer started to realize that
and he was begging him to to get his
face freaking out start freaking out
[ __ ] [ __ ] dude dude they should
have a class like that in school where
they teach you like about scam awareness
like when you're younger so it's like
hey you know look out for these red
flags basic hacking skills well do you
think that they teach kids now like
about online Predators because that's a
[ __ ] rule that's more important than
being scammed is like having some like
dude trying to meet up with you when
you're a kid like that's [ __ ] oh I
know we got Chris Hanson for that we got
they need to teach that [ __ ]
kindergarten
[Applause]
[Laughter]
Ryan's The Stranger
[Music]
[Music]